well we have a very crucial role for
government to play simple but crucial we
need our Congress to put a price on
carbon dioxide fossil fuel needs to pay
the price for the damage it causes in
the atmosphere and that will run up the
cost of gas and oil and everything else
with the result that we quickly put our
economy in the direction of using less
that's the only way we have to
effectively spur this transition from
fossil fuel to something else now we can
do that without bankrupting people there
are good proposals in Congress right now
to take the money generated by that in
essence tax on carbon and rebate it
directly to taxpayers with a check every
month most people would actually come
out ahead unless they were using insane
amounts of energy but we need to do that
nationally and globally just as fast as
we can and we need it to be really
serious and driven by science once
government has done that piece of work
once it's set a price on carbon I think
it would be well advised to step back
and let market forces accomplish much of
what they're capable of accomplishing
once they get the information they need
in the form of that price signal to act
it is something that should have come
out of Copenhagen and out of our own
Congress we've been running the largest
global grassroots climate campaign for
for about a year and a half now
something called 350.org that last
October organized with 5,200
simultaneous rallies in 181 countries
what CNN called the most widespread day
of political action in the planet's
history all geared at trying to build
support for this kind of mechanism and
in Copenhagen we got about a hundred and
seventeen countries to agree with this
call but they were the wrong hundred and
seventeen they were the poorest
countries in the world the most addicted
ones with ours at the lead so far hasn't
done what needs doing
the best data we've got from NASA
indicates that we have to be out of the
business of burning coal entirely on
this planet by the end of the 2020s and
well before that in the Western world
that's an extraordinarily tall order
even just to do it in a perfect world
would be very difficult because it would
mean quickly building up capacity for
wind and Sun and to do it against the
objections of the very powerful fossil
fuel industry is hard as hell so far
we're not moving quickly or really even
at all in that direction we need to very
very badly there's no way to pick up the
pace without doing strong political
organizing this is a political fight in
the end it's the power of people who
care about the future versus the power
of large corporations that care about
their very short-term profit and so far
they're winning and we continue to
organize like crazy at 350.org we've
built the largest movement there's ever
been about any of this but um we need
much bigger
well let's talk first
how difficult it's going to be to keep
infrastructure maintained on the planet
that we're now building the one that's
getting hotter by the minute okay in
that world our infrastructure which is
already decaying and deteriorating comes
under all kinds of stress when there's
flood after flood after flood it gets
very expensive to try to maintain roads
and bridges and everything else I tell
the story in the book of my tiny town in
Vermont which had the two biggest
rainstorms in its history six weeks
apart in the summer of 2008 they washed
out the road to town left us isolated
for days the governor had to come visit
in a helicopter you know we we rebuilt
the road at a cost of a million and a
half dollars to reach 500 people at the
top of the hill that kind of story is
being told all over the planet there's
no way that we can keep up with this
pace of change I think that's why we
need to figure out how to build much
smaller more localized more resilient
communities the infrastructure that
becomes key to that isn't roads and
bridges so much they're still important
but the really crucial infrastructure
for the future is the electronic one
especially the Internet it's our one
wild card and if we're lucky we'll be
able to live pretty decent local
economic lives the way that people did a
long time ago and at the same time
maintain strong links all over the world
not to sell stuff to each other but to
tell stuff to each other to keep in
contact in in in all kinds of good ways
unless of doing business because the
business you need is going to be largely
closed dome in a world that works I your
food is going to come from people that
you know you know people in your general
area your power is going to come from
solar panels on people's roofs from wind
turbines from small hydro from all the
ways we can do it in
gentler fashion but what's going to come
through the internet is information is
ideas is that fresh air that keeps small
towns from becoming parochial it keeps
city neighborhoods from becoming
parochial that kind of contact and it's
very useful thing to have